CALL THE SESSION THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE. DISCOVER THE
USUAL TALKING POINTS TO READ AS
WE CONVENE- WELCOME TODAY'S
HEARING ON S. B. EIGHTY. WE'RE
HAVE A FOR THE DISTANT PERSON
HEARING- AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
IS THE LARGEST ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL WE ARE. ACCOMMODATING A
FEW MEMBERS AND WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE- STAYING
PHYSICALLY DISTANT WITH MINIMAL
STAFF I'M ASKING THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. IN OUR STATE THAT
ONCE THE PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS
IF ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WHICH IS TO SPEAK THEY
CAN. RAISE THEIR HANDS RUSSELL
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. WE
ALSO HAVE PUBLIC COM. AVAILABLE
ON THE PHONE LINE THAT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE TWO SIX TWO FOUR TWO. THE
MANY ISSUES REACHING THE-
GETTING ON TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE PLEASE CALL NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO. NINE NINE. SOME PANELISTS
ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBER WITH
THE ACTION. OKAY YES AND THEN
ADDRESS THE G. PALACE ARE ON
OUR LIVE ONLINE. TO BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IN FOR HEARING MA'AM
MAY PUT- IF PEOPLE A ADVANCE.
THERE'S THERE WILL BE NO IN
COMMITTEE TODAY TODAY WE ARE
HEARING EIGHTY SIX SB EIGHTY
REALLY STARTED AS A JOURNEY
THIS YEAR FOR A NUMBER OF A
WILL ENTER AB TEN IN THE DAY OF.
TO WORK OUR WAY TO TRY TO BE
OPEN SCHOOLS WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF HAVING
SCHOOL OF CLOTHES WHETHER IT IS
LEARNING LOSS WHETHER IT'S
SOCIAL ISOLATION WHETHER IT IS-
DEFECTS IN TERMS OF HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR EDUCATORS. WE
KNOW THAT ONCE IT IS SAFE TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOLS ONCE THERE WAS
A VACCINE ONCE WE COULD-
PROCURE ENOUGH P. P. E. N. KEEP
PEOPLE APART- THAT WE SHOULD GO
AHEAD AND DO SO SB EIGHTY SIX
IS PROVIDING FUNDS FOR LEARNING
RECOVERY AS WELL AS- RE OPENING
SCHOOLS OVER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TO. GIVE INCENTIVES TO
THE DISTRICTS INTO THE
EDUCATORS AND THE PARENTS TO
COME BACK IN SOME FASHION AN
OPEN BACK UP WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS- CAN TAKE ALL THE EXCUSES
OFF THE TABLE. WE KNOW THAT
THEIR NUMBER CONCERNS ABOUT
SAFETY REASONABLE CONCERNS
ABOUT HEALTH AND SAFETY WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE OFFERING THE
RESOURCES SO THAT DISTRICTS
CAN- AND SHOULD OFFER THE
PROPER HEALTH AND SAFETY WE
KNOW THE VACCINATION WAS A
CONCERN. WITH THE GOVERNOR
SETTING ASIDE 10% OF THE
STATE'S VACCINE INVENTORY FOR
EDUCATORS TO PRIORITIZE
EDUCATORS AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. WE BELIEVE IT'S A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EDUCATORS ARE BEING ABLE TO GET
INTO LINE AND GET. VAX
SUMMATION. I TODAY IN TERMS OF-
PANELISTS WE HAVE AND WHOSE THE
SUPPORT PROJECT. MR FOR A
DEPARTMENT FOR AND AMY LEE FROM
THE- ANALYST'S OFFICE- AND THEN
AFTER THE PANEL IS CONCLUDED
WILL GO BACK AND ALLOW MEMBERS
TO ASK AND TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIRS IF HE HAS ANY
OTHER OF COMMENTS. I IT WAS A
CARE- ONE OF THE BIGGEST IS.
FACING OUR STATE IS A
RECOVERING OF. AND I WANT TO
COME THE CHAIR I KNOW HE'S LAZY
FOCUSED ON THIS- WE'RE SEEING.
THROUGH THE NATION BEGINNING
TO- OPEN. AND NOW FOR A PERSON
IN CLASS AND DISCUSS. AND
LEARNING AND THE CITY HAS PUT
OUT THERE GOT SIGNAL TO STATE.
THAT SCHOOLS CARRY A SAFELY.
THE LONGER THAT'S- THEY CLOSE-
THE ACT AND AS AS THE MO
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IN- IT'S LARGER.
AND EACH. EACH DAY WE TALKED
TO. OUR PARENTS ARE SEEING THE
CONCERT. AND EACH DAY MATTER.
HYPER TALK AND I KNOW OF MY
COLLEAGUES EFFORT TALKED THANK
YOU. WITH EDGE SUPERINTENDENTS.
AND EVERYONE BETWEEN OF THE
SCHOOL WE OPENING IS. AND THERE
IS NO DOUBT IN MY- THAT WE NEED
TO REOPEN SCHOOLS ALL GRADE. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. ALTHOUGH
THE HEADLINES- THE FEW TO ARE
ALL. ON SCHOOL READ OPENING IN
THE DEAL WITH IS. US AND WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS. AND ASK
QUESTIONS. THE BIG QUESTION IS
WHAT IS GOING TO. RE WHAT WILL
PERRANCE. AND TEACHERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND THAT MAKES ALL
THE- I LOOK FORWARD T. THE
PARTICULAR. AS A THAT WORK ON
WHAT CAN OF SCHOOL BE. CAL
ACROSS THE STATE- CAN EXPECT IN
THE COMING WE AND MONTHS THIS
BILL IS INTO LAW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FOSTER ME JUST
ALL. A BE REMISS. ALSO LET ME
GET THE OUR- DID YOU. OUR
SIMPLY TO. CHAIR AS WELL AS A-
FAMILY BUDGETS COMMITTEE SO
CHAIR. ARE WORKED WITH ME TO BE
HELP CODIFY THIS DEAL AS WELL
AS- MANY EARLY MAN. OF
COMMITTEE OF FIVE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE BEEN. PH<c.cyan>N. SCHOOL RE</c>
OPENING STARTINGBACK IN
NOVEMBER. SO AGAIN WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS AND- WE
HOPE. THAT THIS WILL REALLY
HELP SPEED UP ALL THE THREE
OPENINGS THE SCHOOL RE OPENING
THAT HAVE ALREADY STARTED. BUT
WILL ALSO IN PARTICULAR
ACCELERATE THOSE. THAT HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO OPEN. QUITE
YET. SO WITH THAT LET ME START.
WITH OUR OWN. BUDGET COMMITTEE
SHE WILL PRESENT. SB EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- GABLE
AND OF ASSEMBLY BUT COMMITTEE-
SPD SIX COMPASS THE THREE
COMPONENTS OF THE STATE SAFE
SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLAN. INTENDED
TO FACILITATE THE SAFE AND
PHASED APPROACH TO RE OPENING
ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO K.
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE. FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION DURING THE
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR. THIS
INCLUDES PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SCHOOL STATUS DATA AND
VACCINES. SCHOOL RE OPENING
INCENTIVE GRANTS AND STUDENT
LEARNING RECOVERY GRANTS. SINCE
WE COVERED THIS BILL IN GREAT
LENGTH LAST WEEK I WILL FCUS
IN MY REMARKS ON THE
DIFFERENCES FROM IN THE
ADDITIONS TO THE SB EIGHTY SIX
VEHICLE THAT YOU HEARD LAST
WEEK. SB EIGHTY SIX WOULD
RETAIN THE DATA AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AS- YOU HEARD LAST
WEEK. BUT ADDS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ENFORCEMENT. TO
FOR THIS BILL. THIS BILL ALSO
WOULD. REQUIRE THE STATE TO
PRIORITIZE ALL TIER ONE BE
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS EQUALLY.
AND INSTEAD OF THEIR IN LIEU OF
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENT YOU HEARD LAST WEEK
WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO
CREATE A 10% SET ASIDE. FOR THE
STATE'S THIRD PARTY VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION CONTRACT FOR
EDUCATION SECTOR WORKERS IN ONE
B. SPECIFICALLY FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND CHILD CARE
WORKERS THAT ARE. OPERATING OR
WORKING ON OPEN CAMPUSES. FOR
RE OPENING IT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION FUNDING SB EIGHTY
SIX WOULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANTS TO EVERY ALLEY A ACCEPT
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS.
TO FACILITATE A SAFE RETURN TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION WITH THE
FOLLOWING CONDITIONS. BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST ELEAZAR SHALL
OFFER IN SCHOOL INSTEAD IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR
VULNERABLE TKA THROUGH TO
STUDENT GROUPS. CERTAIN SMALL
COHORTS USING EXISTING
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SMALL COHORT GUIDANCE. THIS
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO SMALL
COHORTS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF THE TIER
OF THEIR COUNTIES FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSES. THE
DEFINITIONS OF THOSE HORRIBLE
STUDENTS REMAIN THE SAME AS THE
VERSION YOU HEARD LAST WEEK. BY
MARCH THIRTY FIRST IF I COUNTY
IS IN THE PURPLE TEAR. I WITH
CASES LESS THE TWENTY FIVE
CASES PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
IN THEIR POPULATION. ELEAZAR
SHALL RE OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION FOR TKA THROUGH TO
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. SCHOOLS THAT ARE
INTENDING TO RE OPEN FOR TKA
THROUGH TWO AS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE PURPLE TEAR
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
STATE TESTING PROTOCOLS. THEY
ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
THEIR SAFETY PLANS TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT. BY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST OF A. COUNTY IS IN THE
RED TIER ELEAZAR SHALL OPEN FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR T. K.
THROUGH SIX STUDENTS OR
WHATEVER THEIR HIGHEST
ELEMENTARY GRADE IS. SCHOOLS
ARE ALLOWED TO OPEN SOONER WITH
A COVE IT'S- CODE NINETEEN
SAFETY PLAN PURSUANT TO CURRENT
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE. BY
MARCH THIRTY FIRST IF THE
COUNTY IS IN THE RED DEER
ALLEVIATE SHALL RE OPEN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR ALSO AT
LEAST ONE GRADE IN MIDDLE
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL. ONCE AGAIN
CONSISTENT WITH SB EIGHTY SIX
AS YOU HEARD LAST WEEK BUT
CLARIFIED IN THIS LANGUAGE
SCHOOLS THAT CHOOSE TO OPEN
EARLIER BUT HAVE ALREADY
OPENED. OR HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED
A RE OPENING PLAN BUT HAVE NOT
YET BEEN ABLE TO OPEN ARE
ALLOWED TO ACCESS THESE FUNDS
AND TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
UNDER THEIR LOCALLY NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENTS. STUDENT LEARNING
RECOVERY GRANTS. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE FOUR POINT FIVE
SIX BILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR STUDENT LEARNING
RECOVERY GRANTS TO EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT. TO FACILITATE THE
LAUNCH OF A MULTI YEAR LEARNING
LOSS PLAN CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRIOR VERSION OF SB EIGHTY SIX
THAT YOU HEARD LAST WEEK. IT
PROVIDES THESE GRANTS BASED OFF
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FOR IN PERSON
SUPPLEMENTARY INSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES TO ADDRESS LEARNING
LOS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WE'RE GONNA TURN TO MR FERGUSON
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. IF YOU
COULD JUST START I BELIEVE IF
YOU START SPEAKING SHOULD COME
ON THE SCREEN. GREAT THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR- I THINK ERIN'S
PRESENTATION TO SIMPLY COVERS A
MANY OF THE COMPONENTS BABY
EIGHTY SIX. ARE THERE ARE A
COUPLE ADDITIONAL COMPONENTS
THAT I WOULD- NOTE IT DOES THAT
ABDC DOES CONTAIN LANGUAGE- TO
AUTHORIZE THE COMMISSION ON THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO.
WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
CERTAIN STUDENTS TO SUBMIT A
STANDARDIZED TEST SCORE IN LIEU
OF A GPA- THEREBY ENABLING THE
STUDENTS TO BOTH APPLY FOR AND
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A CAL GRANT- AS
WELL AS AB EIGHTY SIX ALSO.
EXTENDS THE TIME LINE FOR THE
EXPENDITURE OF CORONAVIRUS FOR
THE FUNDS ARE PROVIDED TO US
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. I IN LAST
FALL'S BUDGET- WITH THAT- I
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BY SAYING I
THINK THE- YOU AGREEMENT BEFORE
YOU REPRESENTS- WEEK SO A VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN-
THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- THESE EFFORTS
DEMONSTRATE THE HIGH PRIORITY-
ALL PARTIES ARE PLACED ON
RETURNING STUDENTS EDUCATORS
AND STAFF. SAFELY BACK TO
SCHOOLS- AND A CONCLUDE RAIMES
MICHAEL MARKS. YOU WE CAN NOW
TO HELP TO MISTER FROM LA. FOR
ANY COMMENTS. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS A WE WERE THE LARGEST
AND OFFICE SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
REMARKS THAT WE ARE TO AND ANY
TAKEN QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS
HALF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WITH MR OVER TO MA'AM. WHO
QUESTIONS. MISS MCCARTY. THANK
YOU- MISTER BUDGET CHAIR.
BEFORE I TALK ABOUT WHAT BEFORE
US I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OBVIOUS THAT YOU SPEND A LOT OF.
LEADING THE- THE BUDGET. THE
ASSEMBLY THE AKA ABOUT FOR.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S I KNOW WE
WERE- TALKING TO. PEOPLE UP AND
DOWN STATE MAKING SURE WE
ADDRESS THE PRIORITY- OF OUR-
AND- I DO KNOW THAT I HEARD
FROM YOU LATE AT NIGHT EARLY IN
THE MORNING AND WE CAN SO THIS
ISN'T A VICTORY LAP I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT
YOU PUT IN THAT EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT. OF TIME AS DID OUR
KßT STAFF SO JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUT OF OUT OF
THE GATE AND THIS OF COURSE IS
OUR ELUSIVE EDUCATION. BUDGET
CODED PACKAGES IT WILL BE
VOTING ON IT A COUPLE DAYS- I
KNOW THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
WAITING THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT
ON THEIR OWN RIGHT HERE IN OUR
DISTRICT WE HAVE- PROBABLY
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. HAVE ALREADY REOPENED
OR ABOUT TO IN THE COMING
WEEKS. AND OUR GOAL IS FOR THIS
PACKAGE IS TO FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE HELL COULD JOEL
WHATEVER IT TAKES. AS YOU SAID
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A LOT OF
EXCUSES- WE HEARD THAT THE
WISHES TO DO NO HARM PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES HELP US
SECURE VACCINES- A LOT OF THAT
STUFF IS HAPPENING ANYWAY
SOMETIMES BETTER TO BE LUCKY
THAN GOOD- BUT CERTAINLY WE
THINK THAT THIS IS REALLY GOING
TO. ADVANCE THE GOAL IS TO IS
TO GET BACK IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN A SAFE MANNER.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT BUSINESS AS
USUAL WILL BE A HYBRID TYPE
MODEL AND- THEALSO THE ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF
ITS NOT JUST OPENING OUR
SCHOOLS NOW BUT SO MANY OF OUR
KIDS. HAVE THIS TREMENDOUS
LEARNING LOSS AND WE TALKED
LAST TIME ABOUT THE RESEARCH
AND PASTE TALK ABOUT THIRD OF
CAD- AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. HAVE
MONTHS AND MONTHS MONTHS OF
LOSS AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
COME BACK ON- APRIL FIRST FIRST
APRIL FIFTY. MY FIFTEEN THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE- HELLO OF TIME TO
AND- THE MONEY THIS. PART THE
PEACE WHICH I THINK IS. AS A
IMPORTANT. IS THE THIRD LOS
RESOURCE TO FOR ON THE-HE- AND
DOING THAT IN PER. BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT- MORE ZOOM
SCHOOL IS GOING TO FIX THE
WELLS OF THEM SCHOOL. SO- I
THINK THAT THIS- WASN'T.
CLEARLY THE AS AS A AS AS WHAT
WE STARTED IN DECEMBER WITH A
B. TEN BUT IT. IT FOCUSES ON A
LOT OF THE ELEMENTS AND REALLY
ADAPTS TO WHAT. IS HAPPENING
OUT THERE AND YOU KNOW WE WERE
WE WALKED WITH WE WORKED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATORS AND-
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED WORKERS
AND OTHERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- CAN ADDRESS ALL THESE
ISSUES SO- I KNOW WE'RE NOT
VOTING ON TODAY- THIS IS A
CHANCE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
IS. AND I THINK THAT THIS
REALLY SET UP GET OUR SCHOOLS
BACK ON SOME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TURN OVER OUR VICE CHAIR. I
THANK YOU WITH THE CARE- I'VE
QUESTIONS ME TO FROM OF FINANCE
THIS IS BE A AREA I THINK YOU
SHED SOME ON- SOME. MEN OF OUR
DISTRICTS ARE. STILL ON THE-
BECAUSE OF- THE NEED TO SUBMIT
SAFETY PLANS- THE SAFETY REVIEW
WAVE THAT ARE STABBING. AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
TAKING ACTION ON THIS BILL
BEFORE. THOSE WAIVERS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED OR OR IF THEY'RE
DENIED IT OVER THAT MATTER- CAN
YOU GIVE ME A KIND OF A SENSE
OF WHERE WE ARE OR WHERE THE
MISSION IS IN TERMS OF THE
SAFETY REVIEW WAIVERS. HOW
EXPEDITIOUSLY ARE THEY GOING TO
BE REVIEWING THEM. IN APPROVING
THEM HOPEFULLY- IS THERE
FRAMEWORK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS LOOKING AT
TO GET THIS DONE. SURE I'D IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- IS LOOKING AT- THOSE
WAIVERS AND THEY ARE WORKING
YOU KNOW WITHIN THE GUIDANCE.
ARE PROVIDED CHIU- APPROVE
THOSE WAIVERS OF WAR EDUCATE
THOSE WAIVERS- SO CERTAINLY
THAT IS IN PROCESS- AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT BY. THERE
IS AN ATTEMPT TO- PROCESS THOSE
APPLICATIONS AS EXPEDITIOUSLY
AS POSSIBLE. OKAY I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MINISTRATION IS AWARE OF HOW
IMPORTANT THESE LABORS ARE IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY TO COME
BACK TO SCHOOL AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. SO- AND IN TERMS OF
THAT GETTING INTO THE WEEDS A
LITTLE BIT ON THE FOUR POINT
SIX. BILLION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL- AND INSTRUCTOR
EDUCATION- MY UNDERSTANDING IN
READING OF THE BILL IS THAT IT
HAS THE FUNDS HAVE TO BE
EXPENDED- AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO.
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE FUNDS IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SCHOOL YEAR- WHY
WAS AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CHOSEN INSTEAD OF. MAYBE
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
USE UP IN THE YEAR OF A
CALENDAR. YEAR YES VICE CHAIR
AND ERIN CABLE FROM THE- BUDGET-
D. OF LARGEST. AND WAS
EXPRESSED INCOME- WITH. THE AND-
TO REALLY APPROACH LEARNING
RECOVERY COMPREHENSIVELY OVER A
MULTI YEAR PERIOD. THIS EARLY
ACTION FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
BE ABLE TO. START THAT PROCESS
AND SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT TO SUMMER'S WORTH OF
PLANNING AND FUNDING COULD BE
PUT ON THE TABLE AS PART OF
THIS EARLY ACTION PACKAGE TO
ALLOW FOR. A THOUGHTFUL LOCAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
CONSTRUCT THOSE PLANS AND WE
INTEND TO REVISIT- THE FUNDING
LEVELS FOR THOSE PLANS AS WE
GET INTO THE GYM BUDGET. SO IT
COULD BE THAT THEIR- WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL DATES AND FUNDING AS
FAR AS PART OF THAT AS WELL.
OKAY AND THEN- I GUESS MY LAST
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF- TO THE-
TO THE AVERAGE PARENT- THERE
SEEMS TO BE. A BUT CERTAINLY
OCCUR A NEED IN A CONCERN TO
FOCUS ON CATER. SIXTEEN THOUGH
THERE'S IT SEEMS TO BE KIND OF
A PHASE APPROACH. WHAT IS IT I
GUESS THAT IS IN THIS BILL THAT
WILL. GIVE THEM- RELIEF FORCE
OR WHAT WHAT CAN PARENTS ABOUT
MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS EXPECT- IN THIS
BILL. IT SEEMS LIKE THAT. IT'S
ONE GRADE LEVEL- FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL AT SOME POINT AND THEN
THE HIGH SCHOOLS AS WELL. CAN
YOU CAN YOU. I GUESS EXPAND
UPON. WHAT INCENTIVE OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND MIDDLE SCHOOL- HAVE
TO REOPEN QUICKER. SO THE IS
THE SUM TO. EIGHTY SIX TWO A AT
LEAST ONE GRADE MIDDLE SCHOOL
THROUGH HIGH. WAS A NEWMAN
STAND THAT WE WERE INTRODUCED
TO ASPIRIN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO TO.
REPEAT ALL OF THE STANDARDS FOR
RE OPENING THAT ARE CONTAINED
IN SB EIGHTY SIX ARE INTENDED
TO BE A MINIMUM FLOOR. FOR
THOSE I SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ADOPT A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE PLAN ALREADY
TODAY. OKAY I THINK THAT'S ALL
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE AT THE
BIGGEST. THANK YOU MISTER
DONALD. I JUST WANTED TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND ALL THE ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN
MAKING THIS HAPPEN- VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BUT THERE IS
ONE THING I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MONITOR.
AND THAT IS THE- COMPONENT
SPEAKS TO ATTEND FIRST THE 10%
SET ASIDE FOR THE TEACHER
VACCINATIONS. I WAS VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE GET OUR
TEACHERS ACROSSTHE STATE.
VACCINATED OKAY. I'M NOT ASKING
ANY TEACHER TO RETURN TO THE
CLASSROOM WITHOUT BEING
VACCINATED. SAID- THAT YOU KNOW
I WOULDN'T RETURN TO THE
CLASSROOM. WITHOUT BEING
VACCINATED I'VE HAD COVERED I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. THAT
WE GET OUR TEACHERS VACCINATED
I KNOW THAT'S ONE COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL. A 10% SET ASIDE. BUT
I REALLY URGE. THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTING THIS. TO ENSURE
THAT ACROSS THE STATE- WE ARE
MONITORING THE COUNTIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE PUSHING THOSE
VACCINES OUT TO OUR TEACHERS-
WHETHER IT BE THE TWO DOSE
VACCINE NOW APPARENTLY THERE'S
THE ONE DOES THE JOHNSON AND
JOHNSON MAYBE THAT WOULD BE THE
ONE TO SET ASIDE. BECAUSE THE
TIMELINE MIGHT BE TRUNCATED.
FOR TEACHERS TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED I'M NOT A SCIENTIST
I DON'T KNOW. I KNOW SOME
ASIDE- WE DON'T NEED TO DO THAT
THERE'S THE CDC. WELL THE CDC'S
BEEN RATHER INCONSISTENT. ON
WHETHER OR NOT TEACHERS SHOULD
RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM- EVEN
DR FAUCI LAST WEEK. I WAS
WATCHING ONE SUNDAY SHOWS. WHEN
ASKED. WHEN DOCTOR FELT SHE WAS
ASKED IF HE WOULD RETURN TO THE
CLASSROOM AS A TEACHER- HE
WOULDN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT'S JUST COMMON SENSE AND WE
CAN DO IT. SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. THAT WE FOCUS
ON GETTING THOSE VACCINES OUT
AND INTO THE ARMS OF TEACHERS.
SO THAT WE CAN GET OUR KIDS
BACK. INTO SCHOOL. AND ANOTHER
THING THAT WE SHOULD CELEBRATED
JUNE IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN A
LITTLE TOO HERE. IS CERTAINLY
IT'S THE ROOT IT'S GETTING OUR
KIDS BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM
BUT THE LEARNING LOS COMPONENT
WHICH MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SPOKEN. IS FUTURE. IT IS
GIGANTIC. AT LAST IT IS NOT
JUST. A ONE SUMMER THING. AND
IT'S NOT LIKE THE SUMMER SCHOOL
YOU MIGHT ADD. OUR INTENTION OF
THAT THIS BE IS THAT IS THAT
THIS BE. A MUCH MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE SUMMER SCHOOL
APPROACH OVER REALLY TWO
SUMMERS. BUT EVEN IN THE
INTERIM- STUDENTS WILL HAVE
NEEDS ACADEMIC MADE TO SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS MONEY IS SET ASIDE TO
ADDRESS. SO IT'S NOT ONLY
PROBABLY TWO SUMMER SCHOOLS.
BUT A LOT OF WORK TO BRING OUR
STUDENTS. UP TO SPEED IN
BETWEEN. SO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSED ON ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF. COMMENTS SENATORS.
THE FONG NOTICE- I'M A FIRST OF
ALL WHEN I THINK YOU KNOW ALL
OF THEM YOUR WORK ON THIS I
KNOW THAT LOTS OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN- WORKING OVERTIME I'M TO
TRYING TO GET HER KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL ON PARTICULARLY IN MY
DISTRICT ABOUT HALF OF MY
DISTRICT ARE OPEN UNDER WAIVERS
AND HAVE SUBMITTED SAFETY
PLANS. I'M IN MY SENIOR VALLEY
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WANT TO GIVE
A HUGE ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT DR JOSEPH
LYNSKEY WHO GOT ALL TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED OF HIS TEACHERS AND
FACULTY VACCINATED WITH THE
COUNTY OF VENTURA- WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE ROOM REDUCING
NOW REDUCING CASES OF COVE IT-
THE WIDER ACCESS TO VACCINES-
ON THE 10% SET ASIDE- IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FIRST
TEACHERS IN MY DISTRICT- BUT
THE BILL IS I THINK THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP. BUT
FOR ME I DO STILL HAVE CONCERNS
THAT PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
PERTAINS TO OUR JUNIOR HIGH
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS GETTING IN THE
CLASSROOM- CAN YOU. TELL ME
WHAT IN THIS BILL OR WHAT WHAT
DOES THIS BILL DO TO GET ALL OF
OUR MIDDLE CLASS IN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS BACK. TO THE CLASSROOM
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. SO IN
TERMS OF A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL ONCE AGAIN THIS IS
JUST A MINIMUM FLOOR FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- TO GET THEM STARTED
THE INTENT HERE. IS TO-
FACILITATE A SAFE FACED RE
OPENING- OF THERE IS THAT
UNDERLYING BELIEF IN THIS
LEGISLATION THAT ADDS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET MORE EXPERIENCE
WITH SAFELY RE OPENING IN A
PHASED APPROACH IT WILL DEVELOP
THE CONFIDENCE NECESSARY. FOR
PARENTS TO BE WILLING TO SEND
THEIR CHILDREN BACK. AND FOR
EMPLOYEES TO HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO OPERATE SAFELY ON CAMPUS AND
SO. WHILE THIS IS A MINIMUM
FLOOR WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY ELEAZAR ACROSS THE STATE
THAT HAVE MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE OFFERINGS THAT
THEY ARE PLANNING FOR THEIR
MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS. THE
HIGH SCHOOL AND PIECE OF THIS
HAS BEEN HARDER BECAUSE OF THE
TRANSMISSION RATE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN OLDER STUDENTS AND
YOUNGER STUDENTS AND THAT IS
WHY. WE DID NOT SET A MINIMUM
FOR THAT WAS HIGHER FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THIS
LEGISLATION SO THEN AND IS IT
LIKELY THAT OUR HIGH SCHOOL AND
JUNIOR HIGH STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO RETURN TO IN PERSON LEARNING
UNTIL FALL. I THINK THAT THAT
IS. A THIS POINT GOING CONTINUE
TO BE A LOCAL DISCUSSION AND
DETERMINATION. SO ONE OF MY
OTHER CONCERNS- IS AROUND VICE
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE THE
ON HER RETIREMENT STILL OF THE
10% OF FUNDS REPAIR
PROFESSIONALS. CAN YOU CLARIFY
ARE THESE FUNDS ARE WOULD
DISTRICTS BE ABLE TO. HIRE SOME
OF THEIR- PART TIME CARE
PROFESSIONALS INTO FULL TIME.
PER PROFESSIONAL POSITIONS THAT
WOULD BE A LOT YES OKAY. I AM.
I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THE
ISSUE WITH THE TESTING CADENCE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. IF A.
COUNTY IN THE RED TIER HAS
SCHOOLS THAT OPEN BUT THE
COUNTY BACK SLIDES INTO THE
PURPLE TEAR AFTER RE OPENING
WILL THOSE SCHOOLS BE REQUIRED
TO ADHERE TO CD PH TESTING
CADENCE FOR PURPLE TIER
COUNTIES. THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING YES. GREAT THOSE
ARE ALL MY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA. BUT
THANK YOU I'M I'M I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE WHEN
IT WE SEE IT IN THE FIRST THAT
I WANT THE PERFECT TO BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD BUT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHERS AS
THE NAME AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
WELL I HAVE. A LOT OF CONCERNS
THAT WE ARE MAKING IT EASIER
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
BETTER POSITIONED TO OPEN TO
REOPEN AND COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE TO BE AT THE END OF THE
LIST AGAIN FOR THOSE THREE
OPENINGS MY READ OF AFFECTIONS
ABOUT ONE IN FIVE. MY RATE OF
EXCUSES ABOUT ONE IN TWENTY- WE
ARE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND EVEN WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IS NOT CLEAR
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO RE OPEN SAFELY
OUT THERE AND SO I WAS A
TEACHER FOR THIRTEEN YEARS I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS. FOR
KIDS TO GET BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM. I BUT ELSEWHERE TO
MAKE SURE THEY WILL TO GET BY
SAFELY MUCH OF THE- ARE WORRIED
ALSO THE CA. MY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT TENSIONS VISION. THERE
AND WITHOUT GUARANTEE. THOSE
FOR THESE COMMUTER MEMBERS.
WERE NOT GOING TO BE OPEN. AND
I'VE BEEN TO. THAT YOU KNOW MY
SCHOOLS. FROM THAT 10% SET
ASIDE. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE OPEN BUT AS LONG AS WE'RE
NOT BE RE VACCINATING WHENEVER
GOING TO OPEN AND I HAVE. SOME
OF THE HIGHEST LEARNING LOSS.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THE LONGER I WAIT THE
BIGGER IT GETS THE HARDER IT IS
TO FILL IN SO WHILE WE'RE
SETTING ASIDE SOME MONEY FOR
JOINING US. I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
SETTING THIS UP FOR FAILURE.
AND SO I'M NOT GOING TO GET IN
THE WAY OF THOSE THAT ARE
PREPARED TO RE OPEN. BUT I DO
THINK THAT WE ARE. SHORT OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND I
HOPE THAT THE CONVERSATION
QUICKLY. RAMPS UP IN THAT AND I
AM ADVOCATING FOR THOSE
TEACHERS IN THOSE HARDEST OF
COMMUNITIES. TO BE AT THE FRONT
OF THE LINE. ALL OF THEM THAT'S
A TEACHERS THE MOVIE CARE
OLIVER TICKELL IN PLACE AND WE
REALLY WANT TO RE OPEN.
EVERYBODY WORRY ABOUT THE EARLY
LAWS AND EQUITY. THEY NEED TO
BE AT THE FRONT OF THE LINE-
AND SO. I JUST WANT GO ON THE
RECORD OF. THAT ON THAT. I AM
REALLY WORRIED OF. ONCE AGAIN
BEING AT THE END THE LIST I WAS
AT THE IN THE LIST FOR PP. I'VE
BEEN AT THE IN THE LIST FOR
TESTING. FOR VACCINES AND THIS
IS THE BILL ANY DIFFERENT. AND
IT'S HARD TO GO HOME AND FACE
MY CONSTITUENTS. EVERY DAY TO
TELL. THEM WAIT A LITTLE BIT
LONGER. NO SIX. YOU FOR THE
COMMENT THREE THINK YOU'RE-
CORRECT- ESPECIALLY HAVE NOT
DONE WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR SO
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT. ARE
REALLY. AT THE HIGHEST RATE OF
COVERT- BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THOSE ARE PRIMARILY THE HOMES
TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS- THEY ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
THE MOST I THINK WE ACTUALLY
AB. 101% HAVE TO DO. BETTER TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THE- HEALTH CARE RESOURCES
AGAIN THE VACCINATIONS. AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S IN THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR BURKE
CLICK YOU KNOW DOESN'T. DOESN'T
MATTER IF WE ADVOCATE FOR WPF
TO. DELIVER AND WE HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF DELIVERING. TO
ALL THOSE ALL THOSE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS REST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
EQUITY HAS BEEN DISCUSSED. AT
EVERY LEVEL AND WE DO HAVE
COMMUNITIES WHO DO NOT FEEL
THAT THEY HAVE RECEIVED THEIR
FAIR SHARE AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS I KNOW THAT
THAT IS A COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT
FROM THIS HOUSE- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE PUT IN MISTER CHAIR AND-
CHAIR SUB TO MOST MCCARTY. BUT
I MOST ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
THE TEACHERS. THEY NEVER STOP
TEACHING THEY'VE BEEN TEACHING
OUR KIDS DAY IN DAY OUT WEEKEND
EVERY WEEK EVERY MONTH THEY
CONTINUE TO TEACH AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL TO THEM. YES WE HAVE A
LEARNING LOS BUT I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD BE SUFFERING
IF THE OUR TEACHERS HAD GIVEN
UP ON OUR STUDENTS THEY DIDN'T
THEY STAYED WITH OUR STUDENTS
AND I'M EVER SO GRATEFUL TO
THEM. FOR THAT. I APPRECIATE
ALSO AND I HAD A MEETING THIS
MORNING WITH MY DISTRICTS THEY
SINCERELY APPRECIATE BEING
ALLOWED THAT LOCAL CONTROL. TO
BE ABLE TO DECIDE THEY KNOW
THEIR COMMUNITIES BOUNCED. BUT
I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT ALTHOUGH
SOME OF THE DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY DECIDED THEIR SCHOOL
BOARDS OF ALREADY DECIDED. THAT
THEY WILL NOT REOPEN UNTIL THE
FALL. WITH THIS BILL WITH THE
INCENTIVES BEING PROVIDED. I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THEY WILL REVISIT.
THEIR DECISION AND WILL MEET
WITH OUR LOCAL DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT. IN BETTER IT IMPACT OUR
STUDENTS IF APPROPRIATE- THE
PROCESS OF SAFELY RE OPENING
OUR CAMPUSES. HAS BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A BALANCE OF
MAKING SURE STUDENTS DON'T FALL
FURTHER BEHIND IN THEIR STUDIES
WHILE PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF
OUR TEACHERS OR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. AT THE END OF THE
STUDENTS ALL RIGHT I APPRECIATE
THAT THE FOR THE BILL FOCUSES
ON GETTING OUR YOUNGEST AND
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS BACK
ON CAMPUS. INCLUDING OUR
HOMELESS STUDENTS ARE FOSTER
STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS KIDS WHO'VE BEEN
CHRONICALLY ABSENT FROM THAT
DISTANCE LEARNING AND STUDENTS
AT RISK OF ABUSE AND. I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL.
BUILDS ON THE FIFTH. WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR SCHOOLS FROM OUR
FAMILIES FROM OUR COMMUNITIES
FROM OUR TEACHERS ABOUT HOW TO
RE OPEN OUR SCHOOLS IN THE SEPT
SAFEST WAY POSSIBLE. I LOOK AT
THE TIMES THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH AND FRANKLY IT'S
UNIMAGINABLE THAT AFTER A YEAR
WE'RE NOW FINALLY LOOKING AT A
PLAN TO RE OPEN OUR CLASSROOMS-
IT'S AN IMPORTANT DAY AND IT
STARTS WITH US. BEING ON THIS
JOURNEY TO BRING SOME NORMALCY
BACK TO THE LIVES OF OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR CHILDREN. IN
THE SAFEST WAY POSSIBLE. BUT I
HOPE. AND I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FROM LOS
ANGELES I HOPE THAT WE DON'T
FORGET THAT COBIT HOUSE EXPOSE
THE INEQUITIES IN EDUCATION BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO GO AWAY WHEN
CHILDREN TURN TO CLASS ROOM TO
THE CLASSROOM. AND I HOPE THAT
THIS WILL REQUIRE US. TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON RECTIFYING
THIS ISSUE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE EQUITY MUST BE OUR PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THIS REVIEW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SENATOR DINO MY
COLLEAGUE FOOTBALL GUARDIANS-
WE HAVE THIS DOES SAY ISSUES I
HAVE COMMUNITIES ARE VERY VERY
LOW INCOME AND THEN VERY OF
AFRICAN I HAD A SUPERINTENDENT
ROUNDTABLE LAST WEEK AND I HAD
THIRTEEN SUPERINTENDENTS. AND
OF COURSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THERE IT ISSUES WERE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT SO THE POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS- FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY OF THE MONEY
HAS A REALLY HIGH RATE OF
INFECTION EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN
L. A. COUNTY. THE COMMUNITY IS
AFRAID OF GOING BACK AND SOUL
SOUL I ASKED- LAST WEEK IF
BILLS A DISTRICTS WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET A WAIVER- BECAUSE THEIR
INFECTION RATE IS WAIT
SOMETIMES FOUR TIMES AS HIGHER.
AS HIGH AS OTHER NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS AFTER NUMBER ONE THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT I HEARD WAS
FROM MY SUPERINTENDENCIA EFFORT
ON THE MAD RUSH TO SPEND THE
MONEY WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE
MONEY AND IT'S AND I TAUGHT FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS WITH THE SCHOOL
BOARD FOR THIRTEEN AND WE GOT
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE LIKE
IF YOU DON'T SPEND THAT BY
FRIDAY. IT'S GOING TO GO AWAY
SO WE ENDED UP BUYING THINGS
THAT WE WERE OKAY TO BUY AS
OPPOSED TO THINGS THAT WE
REALLY REALLY NEED IT BECAUSE
WE WERE UNDER A TIME FRAME SO I
PLEAD WITH YOU THAT THAT SOME
OF THESE DISTRICTS DO NOT FALL
UNDER THAT YOU KNOW THAT-
DEADLINE IF THEY CAN PROVE OR
THERE'S SOME KIND OF A WAIVER.
THAT RIGHT NOW THE COMMUNITY IS
NOT. READY TO RE OPEN I AGREE
WITH YOU KNOW THE STUDENT
GETTING BACK TO SCHOOL I HAVE A
THIRTEEN AND TWELVE YEAR OLD
AND I'M DYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THEY GO BACK AND
I'M SURE ALL OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE- BUT AGAIN WE CAN'T
TREAT. YOU KNOW ONE DISTRICT
THE SAME AS THE OTHERS L. A.
COUNTY IS HUGE I LIKE I SAID I
AM THIRTEEN I HAVE EIGHTEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND L. A. ONLY
HAS ONE AND SO OBVIOUSLY THE
DIFFERENCES ARE ARE VAST AND
AGAIN I ASK THAT SOME OF MY
DISTRICT ARE SOME OF THOSE
DISTRICTS HAVE I I'M SURE I'M
SURE THAT IT'S NOT JUST MY AREA
THAT THAT WE HAVE THE SAME
DYNAMICS AND- UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. THAT THEY GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AT LEAST
DEMONSTRATE. THAT IT'S NOT
FEASIBLE FOR THEM TO OPEN RIGHT
NOW AND THAT THEY'RE NOT FORCED
TO. THE MONEY JUST FOR THE SAKE
OF. THANK YOU. THANK CABLE DO
WANNA DRESS SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. YES THE- THE REASON
THE LOW. FOR ON REQUIRED THE
SAFE OPEN IT FOR COCA.
REGARDLESS OF ACCOUNT TEAR
RESPECT. OF TRYING TO DRAW
THESE. WE WERE ONCE. THE VERY
STE COHORT GUIDE THAT IS- BEEN
DEEMED TO BE SAFE BY THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
REGARDLESS OF THE LEVEL OF
COMMUNITY SPREAD. TO SIT TO SIT
AS A BASELINE STANDARD FOR T.
CASE THROUGH TWELVE. SO THAT
EVEN IN COMMUNITIES WHERE WE DO
HAVE GREAT CONCERN ABOUT.
COMMUNITY SPREAD OR IF THERE
WERE TO BE ITS TO BE ANOTHER
SURGE IN THE FUTURE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE STUDENTS ARE MOST LIKELY.
TO HAVE ALREADY BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE ACHIEVEMENT. GAP AND NOW
TO BE IMPACTED BY. VERY LOW
SCALE IN TERMS OF LEARNING
RECOVERY. AT THAT THEY'D BE
RECEIVING IN PERSON SUPPORT
IMMEDIATELY AND CONTINUOUSLY.
AND THEN FURTHER- THE ONLY
OTHER REQUIREMENT IN THE PURPLE
TEAR IS AROUND TWO TO THREE
TWO. I WITH THE INCREDIBLY HIGH
TESTING- CADENCES THAT THE
STATE HAS REQUIRED. FOR
SPECIFICALLY THIS PURPOSE SO TO
ENSURE FOR THOSE SMALL GROUPS
OF STUDENTS THE YOUNGER
STUDENTS WERE THE LEAST LIKELY
TO BE TRANSMITTING. AND
CONTRIBUTING TO COMMUNITY
SPREAD THERE ARE STILL SAFETY
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE THAT ENSURE
FOR THE TEACHERS SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND FOR THE
PARENTS OF THERE'S CONFIDENCE
THAT ANY KIND OF- SPREAD THAT
MAY START TO START ON A CAMPUS.
WILL BE DETECTION VERY SWIFTLY
AND CAN BE ACTED UPON. MISTER.
THANK YOU GERMAN. I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
LEARNING LOS- BY RELATING JUST
THE STORY OF ONE YOUNG MAN-
THAT I HOPE I THINK WE'LL BRING
THIS ISSUE ALIVE IF AS I THINK
OF ALL THE BIG STATISTICS OUT
THERE- THERE IS ON- LATINO BOY.
VERY BRIGHT FOURTH GRADER- WAS
ONE OF THE BEST STUDENTS IN HIS
CLASS IN TERMS OF MASS WAS
METICULOUS ON TOP OF EVERYTHING
SCHOOL WORKED WELL FOR ONE WHEN
HE WAS IN SCHOOL BUT ONCE HOME
SITUATION IS SUCH THAT HE DOES
NOT HAVE SUPPORT AT HOME AND AS
COVERT HERE. ONE STARTED
FALLING BEHIND STARTED NOT
GETTING GONE DIDN'T HAVE
SUPPORT WHEN HIS WIFE I DIDN'T
WORK- AND FOR. GRADUALLY FROM
THE SYSTEM AND AS ONE FADED
FROM THE SYSTEM HE FELL BEHIND
IN MATH. AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE LEARNING LOSS IT'S BEEN
REFERRED TO BY. ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE I JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT ONE HOME IF I FALL
BEHIND IN READING IT'S EASIER
TO CATCH UP. BUT IF YOU FALL
BEHIND IN MATH PRETTY SOON YOU
THINK YOU'RE NOT GOOD AT MATH
AND THE MINUTE YOU THINK YOU'RE
NOT GOOD AT MATH YOU'RE NOT
GOOD AT MATH. BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT WILLING TO TAKE THAT THAT
THAT NEXT STEP AND I'M SEEING
THAT IN ONE AND TRYING- TO SEE.
IF WOULD WE DEAL WITH LEARNING
LOSS WE HAVE TO REALIZE SOME OF
THIS WILL BE YOUR REVERSIBLE IF
WE DON'T SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
THINGS LIKE MATH AND MAKING
SURE WE GET. THOSE STUDENTS
BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE AT
LEAST IN THE FOURTH GRADE LEVEL
SO I WOULD JUST OFFER TO THINGS
AND THAT IS WHEN WE PRIORITIZE.
VACCINES FOR TEACHERS WE ARE
ALSO PRIORITIZING. VACCINES FOR
ONE. IN THAT'S ONE OF THE WHY I
HOPE WE DO A GREAT JOB OF THIS
PRIORITIZATION IN IN THAT AND
THE OTHER TING IS THAT I. WANT
TO IMPLORE OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO TRY TO TAKE THIS LEARNING
LOS SERIOUSLY AND NOT JUST SET
UP A WELL WE'VE GOT SUMMER
SCHOOL IF YOU WANT TO COME. BUT
REALLY TRY TO DIG DOWN AND FIND
WHAT ARE THE SPECIFIC LOSSES OF
EACH OF THOSE STUDENTS THAT
THEY SHOULD PARTICULARLY. MUST
CATCH UP ON QUICKLY AND I WOULD
OFFER MATHIS IS PROBABLY IN IN
MY MIND THE MOST CRITICAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISS
KOREA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK ON
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
AS THE MEMBERS INVOLVED AND OF
COURSE THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER. OTHER THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE FORMER TEACHERS. WHO
ARE NOW MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO CAN ADD AN
ADDITIONAL PERSPECTIVE. TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC I HAVE NOT
BEEN A TEACHER BUT I HAVE BEEN
STUDENT. I THINK ALL OF S HERE
HAVE AT SOME POINT. I REPRESENT
L. THE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE LISTED HERE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH.
STUDENTS AT RISK OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT OR WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SOUTH LA NOW A CALLS A- AT.
STUDENTS ENGLISH I LIKE
LEARNERS STUDENTS LACKING TO
ACCESS DISK STUDENTS THIS IS A
PRINTER FOOT PRINT OF EVERY
STUDENT IN MY COMMUNITY AND
WHILE I AM THANKFUL THAT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
REOPENING AND I'M THANKFUL FOR
THE TEACHERS THAT WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE CLASSROOM AND THE
VACCINATIONS THAT ARE GONNA
TAKE PLACE. I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT WE ARE LIVING IN THEM IN
ALMOST THE A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY BECAUSE WE CAN'T. WE
CAN'T JUST SIMPLY RE OPEN
SCHOOLS. AND VACCINATE TEACHERS
WITHOUT LOOKING AT THE HOT
ZONES IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE STUDENTS AND THOSE KIDS ARE
COMING FROM. SEVERAL OF US IN
HERE HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
MONTHS. TO DO HOT STONE
VACCINATION. BECAUSE WHAT IS
THE POINT OF VACCINATING A
TEACHER AND RING OPENING
SCHOOLS WHEN YOU HAVE A
FINANCIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
PARENTS. WHO ARE MAYBE A COOK
IN THE BACK OF A RESTAURANT. IN
A KITCHEN SOMEWHERE WHO DOES
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE VACCINE.
THOSE FAMILIES ARE STILL
EXPOSED THOSE CHILDREN ARE
STILL EXPOSED AND WE ARE
EXPOSING TEACHERS BY DOING THE
SAME. SO I WOULD JUST IMPLORE
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
WHOEVER IS LISTENING WE HAVE TO
RETHINK AND REIMAGINE. OUR
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION PLAN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
REALLY THINK ABOUT AN EQUITY
LENS IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP A
LOT. WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR MONTHS BUT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO CORRELATION RIGHT
NOW. IN TERMS OF HOW WE ARE
VACCINATING HOT ZONES. WERE
MOSTLY. OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
LATINOS. ARE HIGHLY IMPACTED
AND DYING STILL EVERY DAY. FROM
THIS TERRIBLE. VIRUS AND WE'RE
TALKING AS IF NONE OF THAT IS
REAL. I EXPERIENCE IT EVERY DAY
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY THAT ARE DYING EVERY
DAY. AND WE HAVE THESE HUGE
VACCINE SITES THEY'RE NOT BEING
USED BY THE PEOPLE OF MY
COMMUNITY. MORE REPORTS REPORTS
AND ARTICLES IN IN EVERY
NEWSPAPER ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
SIGNIFIED HAVE SIGNALED HOW.
ARE EQUITY PROGRAM IS NOT
WORKING. AND SO I'M JUST I'M
CONCERNED I'M WORRIED AND I
WANT TO HAVE IT ON RECORD. THAT
THIS WELL THIS IS A GOOD STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IT DOES
NOT ADDRESS OUR HOT ZONES IT
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE PARENTS OF
THE CHILDREN OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. IN THE DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF EQUITY.
ON THE VACCINE ROULETTE BUT YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
BEING DONE BUT THERE'S STILL SO
MUCH MORE THAT WE NEED TO AND
HAVE TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MY QUESTION IS-
REGARDING THE DIFFERENT
DEADLINES AND TIMELINES THE-
ARE- PUT OUT HERE AS FAR AS
MARCH THIRTY FIRST AND THEN
LOSING- BY APRIL FIRST- 1% FOR
EACH DAY IN PERSON ULTIMATELY
LEADING TO A MAY FIFTH-
FORFEITURE OF THE MAY FIFTEENTH
FOR THE FOR FORFEITURE OF THE
FULL GRANT. ARE WE SETTING UP
ALLEY ACE TO BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE AN ADEQUATE PLAN IN
THIS TIME FRAME N. F. L. LIAISE
ARE WORKING TOWARDS THAT PLAN
IS THEIR WORK ABILITY WITH THE
ALLEY ACE TO MAKE SURE THEY
COMPLY GIVING THEM- SOME TYPE
OF- HONOR SYSTEM MOVING TOWARDS
GETTING TO THAT POINT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
TIME FRAME AND THE DISCUSSION
OF HOW WE CAME UP WITH THOSE
DEADLINES. THERE WAS INPUT ON
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS
CONTABILIDADE THAT ALLEY ASIAN%
THE STATE COULD COMPLY WITH
THESE DEADLINES THAT ARE HERE
BEFORE THE FORFEITURE OF
GRANTS- BY MAY FIFTEENTH. THANK
YOU SO THE WAY THAT THE FUNDING
WOULD WORK IN A SPECIFIC TO THE
TWO BILLION FOR RE OPENING
GRANTS- AND BE ALL OF THE
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE- AWARDED
TO ELIE A SPACE UP THERE L. C.
F. F. SO ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
FUNDING. IN THE PENALTIES BEGIN
FOR EACH DAY STARTING APRIL
FIRST UNTIL MAY FIFTEENTH THAT
THEY HAVE NOT OPENED FOR
EXACTLY THAT PURPOSE YOU JUST
EXPRESSED A SEMI MEMBER IT IS
INTENDED. TO ALLOW THOSE
ELEAZAR WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO
MEET THE STRICT REQUIREMENTS OF
MARCH THIRTY FIRST BUT DO YOU
IN GOOD FAITH ADOPT A RE
OPENING DATE BETWEEN MARCH
THIRTY FIRST AND MAY FIFTEENTH.
TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A PORTION
OF THAT FUNDING TO ACCOMMODATE
THE EXPENSES THEY WILL HAVE FOR
SAFELY RE OPENING. MR IF I MAY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT TIME
FRAME IS ENOUGH AN ADEQUATE
TIME FOR ALLEY ACE TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLY. WITH THE PLAN THAT
IS ACCEPTABLE- FOR TO CONTINUE
THE GRANT- FUNDING TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD TO ALLIE X. WE
DO. THANK YOU AND THEN JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION ON THE TWO YEARS
WITH THE COUNTIES- IF THE
COUNTY DOES SLIP. BACK INTO THE
HIGHER TIER. DOES THAT MEAN
THAT LOCAL ALLEY AS THAT WOULD
HAVE TO ADJUST AND THERE COULD
BE A COMPONENT OF OPENING AND
CLOSING. WITHIN THE SCHOOLS
ITSELF BASED ON THAT TIER OF
THE COUNTIES. SO THE WAY THAT
IT WORKS UNDER CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE SAFELY RE
OPENED WITHIN A WITHIN ADOPTED
PLAN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THAT
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE A GUIDING
THEIR OPENING AND CLOSING.
DECISION MAKING AND THEY'RE
TESTING THEIR DISTANCE SAYING
ALL OF THESE REQUIREMENTS WOULD
BE. GRANDFATHERED IN SO IF THEY
WERE TO HAVE. LET'S SAY-
SLIPPED FROM THE RED TEAR BACK
INTO THE PURPLE TEAR AT ANY
POINT. THEY ARE- SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS INSTRUCTION TO THEIR
STUDENTS- UNTIL THEY HAVE BEEN
ORDERED TO BE CLOSED BECAUSE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO WHAT YOU WILL
SEE IS IF FOR EXAMPLE THEY WERE
IN THE RED TEAR AT THE WOULD
HAVE BEEN OPERATING UNDER THEIR
RED TIER REQUIREMENTS. IF THEY
SLIPPED BACK INTO THE PURPLE
TEAR. THEY WOULD THEN SHIFT TO
THEIR LOCAL PLANTS PURPLE TIER
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THOSE ELEAZAR
WHO HAVE NOT ADOPTED A PURPLE
TEAR PLAN BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST
THE DEFAULT WILL BE THE STATE'S
PURPLE. REQUIREMENTS AND SO
THEREFORE IF THEY WERE TO HAVE
SLIPPED FROM RED TEAR. INTO
PURPLE TEAR THEY WOULD GO BACK
INTO THOSE REQUIREMENTS BUT- IT
ALSO IS VERY CLEAR THE
LEGISLATION. THAT THE INTENT IS
FOR CONTINUOUS STUDENT
INSTRUCTIONS SO ONCE AN ALLEY
A- HAS DETERMINED HOW TO SAFELY
RE OPEN. AND STARTED OFFERING
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO THOSE
STUDENTS TO THOSE CHILDREN.
THEY ARE INTENDED TO DO SO
UNTIL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS THEM
TO BE CLOSED. THERE ARE CURRENT
PROGRAM ENTERS IN THE GUIDANCE
FOR WHEN THEY DO NEED TO CLOSE.
BASED OFF OF AN INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL SITES SPREAD INFECTION
LEVEL. AS WELL. AS AROUND
COMMUNITY SPREAD. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WHAT. YES THANK YOU LIST
THANK YOU EVERYONE WHO FOR ALL
THE INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS AND
I. I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS I
JUST I JUST HAD A QUESTION- IS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET BACK TO IN
PERSON LEARNING. IS THERE ARE
THERE ANY REQUIREMENTS ON WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE COULD BE AN
HOUR A DAY OR IS IT A FULL DAY
OF LEARNING- IS THAT COMPLETELY
AT THE DISCRETION OF DISTRICTS
SO. COULD THEY ARE TECHNICALLY
OPEN FOR AN HOUR AND RECEIVE
THIS FUNDING- I JUST YEAH IS IT
IS BECAUSE I DON'T FEEL LIKE
THAT'S REALLY OUR INTENT BUT
BUT I DON'T KNOW I MEAN COULD
THEY DO THAT. THE BILLS AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN ONCE AGAIN AS
A MINIMUM STANDARD DOES NOT SET
A MINIMUM STANDARD FOR THE
NUMBER OF IN PERSON
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES OR IN
PERSON. A SERVICES SO THAT
WOULD BE A LOCAL DECISION. OKAY
SO I DID HEAR FROM- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MADONNA DONNA FROM- ARE
CALLING FROM A LONG BEACH THESE
ME- AND HE TALKED ABOUT SUMMER
SCHOOL- AND- BUT I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING IN THERE REALLY
ENCOURAGING SUMMER SCHOOL SO
THAT'S ALL GOING TO BE
COMPLETELY AT THE DISCRETION OF
LOCAL DISTRICTS AS WELL OR DID
I MISS SOMETHING. SEVEN PM
LANGUAGE AROUND THE LEARNING
RECOVERY IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU ADOPTED
IN THE BUDGET ACTOR
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. SO WE HAVE
A MINIMUM INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES
PERIOD IN THE EDUCATION CODE-
AND SPECIFIC TO IN DISTANCE
LEARNING RIGHT NOW WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT ROUGHLY TO A MINIMUM
DAY. FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
SO THOSE MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME WHETHER IN
DISTANCE LEARNING OR IN PERSON
WOULD REMAIN IN PLACE BUT IT
WOULD BE A LOCAL DISCRETION. AS
TO WHICH COMBINATION OF EACH TO
ACHIEVE THE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION REQUIREMENTS IN SB
EIGHTY SIX. SPECIFIC TO THE
LEARNING RECOVERY FUNDS THOSE
ARE TO BE A SPECIFICALLY IT
CALLS OUT OF THOSE ARE
SUPPLEMENTARY TO THE
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES. SO THERE
ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS TO THAT
LIKE ONE ON ONE TUTORING OR
SMALL GROUP PULLOUT. WHERE YOU
COULD SEE A STUDENTS LEARNING
RECOVERY PLANNING DURING THEIR
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME WHERE
THEY'RE GETTING SOMETHING.
DIFFERENT IN SIGNIFICANT
INTENSIVE BUT THE INTENT
OVERALL IS THAT IF IT IS. AFTER
SCHOOL BEFORE SCHOOL SUMMER
SCHOOL THE OUR INTENSIVE
SUPPORTS THAT ARE ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE INSTRUCTIONAL DAY.
SO AND THEN I GUESS MY FINAL
QUESTION DO WE HAVE ANY
INDICATION OF. HOW MANY SCHOOLS
WILL ACTUALLY TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT- IN THE
INTERESTS OF. HELPING STUDENTS
RECOVER. I THINK THAT IT'S FAIR
TO SAY THAT THE LEARNING
RECOVERY PART OF THIS BILL HAS
BEEN UNIVERSALLY APPRECIATED BY
EDUCATION LEADERS ACROSS THE
STATE- THE EDUCATORS MANAGEMENT
FOLKS ARE VERY- EAGER TO START.
LAYING A PATH FORWARD FOR IN
PERSON SUPPLEMENTARY LEARNING
RECOVERY EFFORTS. AND TEACHERS
HAVE AS WELL AS USE OF OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU. IT AND IT JUST
IT JUST OF BIRTH FOR THE
CLARIFY THE WAY THE FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION. IN LEARNING
COVERING WAS STRUCTURED- 85% OF
IT HAS TO BE USED FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. SO WHAT THEY CAN
DO SOME LEVEL OF ONLINE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING- THE BALL
BECAUSE IT REALLY HAS TO BE
USED FOR IN PERSON. MISTER
JONES SAWYER. AND I JUST WANNA
GO TO STEP BY A COMMENT- I'M IN
WINDOWS NEED CITY WHERE UP I
HAVE THE MOST LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- MEMBERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I HAVE THE MOST
CHARTER SCHOOLS. THE SECOND
MOST CHARTER SCHOOLS IN MY
DISTRICT MY CALLING TO THE
NORTH HAS THE MOST CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE SECOND MOST L.
UFT SCHOOLS AND SO WE REPRESENT
A LARGE SWATH OF WHAT'S GOING
ON- AND I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT LEARNING LOSS- MY
DAUGHTER. IS A HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER IF YOU TALK TO ANY MATH
TEACHERS THEY WILL TELL YOU
THAT IF YOU COULD MATCH THE
MATH YOU CAN MASTER ANYTHING IN
THE WORLD. AND SHE WANTS TO BE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS ONE
DAY AND SHE'S ALWAYS TOLD ME IF
I CAN GET EVERY STUDENT IN MY
DISTRICT TO MASTER. ALGEBRA IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO GET TO COLLEGE BE ABLE TO
FILL AN APPLICATION BE
SUCCESSFUL. IF YOU MISSED THAT
IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL. THAT
COULD BE DEVASTATING FOR THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE AND SO THAT'S
WHY LEARNING LOSS IS SO
IMPORTANT SPACE FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO STUDENTS.
WORKER IT JUST FEELS LIKE AND
THIS IS WHAT I GET FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS IT ALMOST FEELS
LIKE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PANDEMIC WHEN IT COMES TO
SCHOOLS ARE SOMETIMES OUR
POLICIES ARE ALMOST LIKE BACK
AT A BUS KIND OF POLICIES- LIKE
ROSA PARKS AND WHAT SHE DID
DOESN'T MATTER WE STILL ARE
DOING THINGS WHERE. IN MY
DISTRICT. AN FORTY SIX AN ADULT.
I SAW MORE MERCEDES LEXUS AND
PEOPLE IN LAWN CHAIRS ORDING
COOPER EACH TO GET VACCINATED
THEY DIDN'T LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHAT THE COMMUNITY
IS LOOKING ALL OF WHAT'S GOING
ON PEOPLE WERE JUMPING THE LINE.
I JUST DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN WITH OUR MOST PRECIOUS
CARGO WHICH IS OUR KIDS. THAT
ISRAEL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE PRESSED TO THE
BACK ALIVE ECAUSE OTHERS HAVE
IT HAVE MORE RESOURCES. THE
ABILITY TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL DEBILITY SENT TO
SCHOOLS THAT ARE ALREADY UP AND
RUNNING. BUT WE'RE TRAPPED
HERE- NOT PROVIDING ENOUGH
RESOURCES. BUT MOST IMPORTANT
IF THEY'RE NOT PUT TO THE FRONT.
OF THE LINE YES WE NEED TO DO
PUT WHERE THE HOT SPOTS ARE THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED TO THE FRONT
OF THE LINE AND THEN WE START
TO TAKE CARE IT IS CRITICAL
PROBLEM AND SO HOPEFULLY IN.
THIS THEY ARE VOTING FOR
CUTTING BEGINS THE PROCESS OF
ACTUALLY FOCUSING IN DOWN EAST
LA SOUTH LA AND THERE MIGHT. MY
COLLEAGUE TO THE SOUTH ALSO
MENTIONED- THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE HAPPENING THAT WE PRIOR TO
RISE TO A COURT ORDER. WHERE MY
NORTHERN CALI ME AND MY
SOUTHERN KILEY. WE CAN GET TO
RESEARCH SOURCES WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. WHEN THIS IS OVER
WE'RE ALREADY BEHIND THINK
ABOUT IT WE WERE ALREADY BEHIND.
IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING NOW WE
COULD LOSE GENERATIONS AND
GENERATIONS TO POVERTY. AND
THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE
ON OUR WAY TO FOR THEM TO HAVE
A BETTER LIFE SO THANK YOU
MISTER. WELCOME BACK TO OUR
ROSTER. SOME OF THE TABLE
ACTION WILL COME FOR THANK YOU
MR CHIU AND TO I THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE- OF REMARKS THAT ALL OF
YOU HAVE MADE I REPRESENT- A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF
COURSE AS WELL- AND SOME OF
MINOR BETTER OFF THAN OTHERS
BUT ABOUT HALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS- OF ACCESO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE- FOR THEIR-
CHILDREN. I AND I WANT TO JOIN
MIKE WHO SPOKE SO L. ABOUT THE-
IMPORTANCE OF- OF MAKING
CERTAIN THAT WE DO NOT ALLOW
CHILDREN TO FALL FURTHER BEHIND
SIMPLY BECAUSE- OF WHERE THEY
LIVE OR THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN- OR ANY OF THE OTHER
EQUITY FACTORS- THAT ARE IN. IN
PLAY HERE WE SIMPLY CAN'T DO
THAT LEASE- SUFFERS A SOCIETY-
AND AS INDIVIDUALS. THE FURTHER
THAT DIVIDE GROWS- IT'S
REFLECTED IN FISHERS IN OUR
SOCIETY- AND- IT WOULD BE
OUTRAGEOUS IF THE ACTION THAT
WE TAKE HERE TODAY- WERE TO
FURTHER EXACERBATE THAT- I KNOW
THAT NONE OF US WANT TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN CERTAINLY NOT TO
ART ARE CHAIR ANY OTHER MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE. ALL THE
SUPPORTING. OF THIS BILL TODAY
IS A STEP FORWARD- BUT I THINK
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. I THINK A LOT
OF THE- PARENTS WHO ARE
FOLLOWING THIS DEBATE- I THINK
THAT WE ARE. JUST YOU KNOW HERE
TO REOPEN SCHOOLS AND- YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD FLIP A SWITCH AND
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN AND THAT
CLEARLY IS NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE IT'S NOT PRACTICAL IT IS
NOT 1100% ARE- WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION TO DO- HI. ADAM
AND I. DO HAVE A QUESTION
THAT'S RELATED TO THAT THOUGH-
WE ARE- CURRENTLY TALKING ABOUT
ONLY A FRACTION OF STUDENTS.
WHO THROUGH OUR ACTION TODAY
OR- WHEN THIS- PRESUMABLY
PASSES- ON BOTH FLOORS OF THE
LEGISLATURE- WILL BE
INCENTIVIZED. TO THROUGH THEIR
SCHOOL TO- TO RE OPEN FOR A
SEGMENT SO IF YOU'RE IN THE
PURPLE CARE IT'S- THE- COHORTS
THAT ARE LISTED AND T. K.
THROUGH TWO IF YOU'RE IN THE
RED TEAR THAT INCREASES TO T.
K. THROUGH SEX- AND- ONE GRADE.
OF SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE. MIKE A
QUESTION IS THAT THE- I THINK
IT'S LAUDATORY OF THAT- WE ARE
HOPEFULLY GOING TO BE SEEING-
AND- IN THE VERY VERY NEAR
FUTURE THOSE STUDENTS IN THOSE
COHORTS RETURNING TO SCHOOL-
BUT IT'S NOT ALL OF THE
STUDENTS AND SO I MY QUESTION
IS- WHAT IS THE PLAN. GOING
FORWARD TO- ANNA AND IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THE FOLDER PASSING
TODAY THAT. SETS MOTION
PLANNING FOR- NEXT STAGES. OF
RETURN. YES THANK YOU SO THE-
THERE ARE PLANS ACROSS STATE
FOR LOCAL SCHOOLS AGO
OBVIOUSLY- SENIOR OWN DISTRO
THERE ARE MANY THAT ARE MUCH
MORE PROGRESSIVE THAN THIS
MINIMUM STANDARD THAT WE ARE
SETTING IN THIS LEGISLATION.
THIS LEGISLATION IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE NOT MADE PROGRESS
TOWARDS EVEN A MINIMUM PHASE
THREE OPENING APPROACH- AND
HAVE REMAINED CLOSE TO HAVE
PLANNED TO REMAIN CLOSE TO THE
END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR. AND SO
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY A DISTANCE
LEARNING AUTHORITY DOES EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THIS SCHOOL YEAR
AND I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR HAS
EXPRESSED IN THAT OF MANY
MEMBERS HAVE HAVE EXPRESSED
INCLUDING. SOME MEMBER
O'DONNELL- IN INTENT TO NOT RE
AUTHORIZE A BLANKET DISTANCE
LEARNING AUTHORITY FOR THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR SO THAT IF THAT
WERE TO BE THE ACTION TAKEN IN
JUNE AS PART OF THE BUDGET IT
WOULD LEAD TO A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE. RE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS. SO ARE I ENTER. THE
WHAT DO- JUST TOLD US- JUNE BY-
IS THE TIME THAT WE WOULD- A
PROVIDE FOR FURTHER INCENTIVES
THE JUNE BUDGET WILL BE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR IN TERMS OF
WHAT SCHOOL LOOKS LIKE IN THE
FALL SO THIS IS INTENDED TO BE
FOCUSED ON SAFELY RE OPENING
THIS SPRING ALONG. OKAY THANK
YOU. MY QUESTION IS I GUESS- TO
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
WITHIN A ROSE- I KNOW THAT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
PRESENTED AN ANSWER ON WHAT-
WHAT SCHOOL WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
HOW MANY HOURS WOULD BE-
PROVIDED IN PERSON AND THAT
WOULD BE UP TO- THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BY IF I COULD ASK THE
BOMB OF FINANCES ADMINISTRATION
HAVE A PREFERENCE OR DO THEY
ENVISION AND A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF OR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION-
THAT THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS WHAT ONE IS
WANT TO SEE- IN SCHOOLS. I
THINK WHAT WE WHAT WE WOULD
LOOK AT THE GUIDANCE WE WOULD
LOOK TO- CO WITH SAFETY PLANS-
AND CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LEGISLATION
THAT IS BEFORE- THIS BODY.
WHICH DOES PROVIDE FOR LOCAL
DISCRETION IN DETERMINING THE
MOST APPROPRIATE- YOU KNOW
ACTION- FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND HOW THEY
WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT REAL. OKAY
SO SEVEN AND S. OF THE- I MEAN
THE MAN OF. AND PERSON STILL
HAS TO BE WORKED OUT WITHIN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THAT AND
THAT'S HOW IT'S ENVISIONED.
BOTH AIR AND DEPART FINANCE NOW
THIS WOULD GO. SO DID. FOUR OF
THE SITE HI ADDITION AS ABOUT
THE SAME TIME AND GOT. I WOULD
I WOULD JUST REITERATE THAT OF
FINE OF REMOTE THE DIDN'T
MINIMUM FLOOR FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES IN THE SPRING- REMAINS
BUT THE- DIVISION BETWEEN IN
PERSON AND ONLINE INSTRUCTION
WOULD REMAIN LOCAL DECISION
THROUGH THE SPRING. OKAY AND
THEN- MAYBE YOU CAN CLARIFY I
KNOW THE LIGHT- MY PUBLIC
SECTOR BUT SINCE THERE'S SOME-
AS A- HI MY AND IN CADENCES.
CAN YOU JUST WALK ME THROUGH
THAT- TESTING CADENCE AND WHAT
ALLOWED SO IF YOU HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS- MOVING FORWARD
WITH THEIR PLAN- ALREADY THEN
THEY WOULD THEN BE
GRANDFATHERED IN AND WOULD HAVE
A TESTING CADENCE OF. ONCE
EVERY TWO MONTHS AND THEN IT
BUT IF THEY WORD TO- AND NOT IN
AN OPEN UNDER THESE NEW
GUIDANCE IS- AT BEFORE APRIL
FIRST- THEN IF THERE IT DEPENDS
ON THEIR TEARS OF THEIR IN THE
RED HERE THEY WE TEST. EVERY
WEEK AND THEN IF THERE AND- OF
THAT AND THE RED IT HAS EVERY
TWO WEEKS AND IF THEY'RE IN THE
PURPLE THEY WOULD TEST EVERY.
WEEK IS THAT CORRECT. SO THAT'S
THE ONLY- TO CORRECT ME IF I
GET THIS WRONG BUT- THE- THE
TESTING CADENCES OF THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE PURPLE
TIER. WOULD BE THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS IF THEY HAVE NOT
ADOPTED THEIR OWN LOCAL PLAN
AROUND TESTING- BY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST. SO THEN IF THEY ARE IN
THE RED TEAR OR BETTER. IT IS A
LOCAL TESTING CADENCE OF JUST
NEED TO REPORT INTO THEIR
COVERED SAFETY PLAN. SO THERE
AT THE STATE DOES HAVE GUIDANCE
THEY HAVE ADVICE BROWN TESTING
CADENCES IN THE RED TEAR- FOR A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING AND THEN
THEY HAVE. GOT REQUIREMENTS FOR
TESTING RUN SYMPTOMATIC TESTING
IN THE ORANGE TEARS AND BETTER.
BUT THOSE WOULD REMAIN AS-
GUIDANCE NOT A REQUIREMENT
UNDER THIS BILL. THE
DIFFERENCES THE PURPLE TEAR SO
THE PURPLE TIER TESTING
CADENCES. WHICH ARE-
RECOMMENDED CURRENTLY BY THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH FOR A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING. OF TWICE
WEEKLY FOR STAFF AND STUDENTS.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A LOCAL PLAN
PRIOR TO MARCH THIRTY FIRST
THAT TESTING WOULD BE REQUIRED
IN PURPLE. THE TWICE WITH IN
THE- AND THAT ACTUALLY AS IT
AND I SENT TO MY FINAL IN A IS
TO THE- IN TERMS OF. I NOW AND
WHAT IS WHAT IS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON. ON THIS ON THIS
BILL- IF YOU'VE A HAD A CHANCE
TO DIGEST EVERYTHING. SURE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
DEALING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE BUT- TWENTY TWO ALSO UP
OF THE BILL ABEYTA FROM INNER
CITY IT DOES ADDRESSED SEVERAL
THE CONCERNS WE RAISED IN. BUT
AGE- WE MEN THAT THE TIME FOR
WOULD OPEN TO UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S- AB AND ASK THE
EIGHTY SIX YOU LOOK BACK AT
LINES I THINK. PRICE. PERFECT
TIME FOR DISTRICTS TO PLANT.
THANK THE STATE FIRST- AND THAT
IS EXACTLY SB AB IS DIES I'M
ALSO THAT THE TEST REQUIREMENTS
RATHER AND THAT COULD BE PAIN
I'M DIST FROM OPENING- GIVEN
THAT THERE ARE NO FLEXIBILITY
CENTER AND SHE IN THIS BILL WE.
EXACTLY IN IN JANUARY A
GOVERNMENT. GREAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY SEEING
NONE LET'S GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE GALLERY. OKAY I'M NOT
SEEING ANY IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE. OPERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO USING YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE OR YOUR TELEPHONE PHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL- LINES IN Q. ARE
YOU READY FOR THE FIRST YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE
TWELVE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH
ASK ABOUT A WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS REPRESENTING TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICER STATEWIDE. DURING THE
PANDEMIC LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES HAVE BILL CONTINGENCY
PLAN FOR MULTIPLE BUDGET
FUNDING. AND STAFFING CAPACITY
AS THEY SCALE UP IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND SERVICES WE
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND BELIEVE THAT
STILL BRINGS A BALANCED
APPROACH TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATIONAL STAFF HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE. AS THEY
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OUR BEGIN
TO PROVIDE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE AND FULLY SUPPORT
THE PREPARATION OF THE SIX
POINT FIVE SIX BILLION DOLLARS
TARGETED AT SUPPORTING IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. AS
ELLIE EIGHT BEGAN TO SCALE UP
AND OUR OFFER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE AND PROVIDE
IMPLEMENTATION FEEDBACK TO KEEP
BOTH ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE INFORMED ON THE
PROGRESS MADE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO MEET THE STUDENTS
ACADEMICS AND EMOTIONAL. SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMENT THANK YOU FROM
LINE NINE LINE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MARKING
AMADO- HE CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK ALSO A FAMILY
MEMBER OF TWO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
A MEMBER OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE JUST WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING UP THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARDS-
REOPENING. OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND JUST WANT TO JUST
COMMENT- ON THE ISSUES OF
EQUITY IN OF AN APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT COOLEY NOT ONLY IN
THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE
URBAN AREAS AND RURAL AREAS BUT
ALSO EQUITY REGARDING PEOPLE IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE ACCESS TO
SERVICES THAN WHITE BY ARE NOT
ALWAYS AVAILABLE AND LASTLY-
THE ISSUES OF OVERSIGHT THAT
WERE RAISED BY SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE THE SPECIAL
THAT- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
EFFORTS AND APPRECIATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FOURTEEN
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JONATHAN OFFICER IT
WELL WE CAN CAL. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING TODAY ALTHOUGH
COMMITTEE ON THE GENERATION FOR
SB. I'M NOT I. IT'S NOT YOU CAN
I DO SUPPORT SERVICE. HE COULD
HAVE A. ONE ONE EIGHT. LAUGHTER
IT WILL JUST BE MUCH WE- I'M
CONCERNED DIDN'T WE SENT TO
MEET OUR WORK LIKE YOU KNOW I
DURING SCHOOL. HOUSING THE A
SCHOOL WE OPEN A LOT OF TRICKS
AMERICA BY CONSIDER WE ADDRESS
MANY DISTANCE THAT THE LEAST
ALLOCATE WANTED TO GO BACK TO
PAY SERVICES USING RECEIVE. IF
YOU'RE. NEXT IN LINE EIGHTEEN
ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR- BY
SHARING MEMBERS AND STAFF
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION WE JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL AND REALLY EXPRESS OUR
SINCERE APPRECIATION TO STAFF
AND MEMBERS. FOR THE CALIPARI
PUT INTO WORKING WITH US TO
RESPONDING TO OUR CONCERNS
PARTICULARLY AROUND OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ISSUES
AND VACCINE ROLLOUT AND AN
ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS AND
REALLY ULTIMATELY ARRIVING AT A
PLACE THAT WE BELIEVE WILL GET
MORE KIDS BACK INTO SCHOOL.
QUICKLY PRACTICALLY AND SAFELY
ON THE OTHER THAT THE DA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE SPLIT THE BILL.
NEXT WE HAVE A LINE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. EACH YEAR OUR
FRONTLINE TRANSIT WORKERS
PROVIDE MILLION TO TRICKS TO
KEEP YOUR CALL STUDENT CREATING
DIRECT ACCESS TO SCHOOLS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC SOME
TRANSIT AGENCIES EVEN CREATED
MOBILE HOTSPOT SUPPORT
DIFFERENT FLOORING. MORE
GENERALLY ARE WORKERS RESPOND
EVACUATION ORDERS EXPAND ECKEL
ACCESS TO TESTING AND
VACCINATION TYPE IN THE PROVIDE
MEDICAL TRIPS TO SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. YET
KNOW WHERE IN THE STATE
GUIDELINES FOR BACKING
DISTRIBUTION FOR THE SECTORS OF
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE
EMERGENCY SERVICES OR
HEALTHCARE OR TRANSIT WORKERS
NAME FOR GRANTED PRIORITY
ACCESS TO THE CLUB IN NINETEEN
BACKSEAT. THIS IS EVEN AT
SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS PERFORMING A
FUNCTIONALLY SIMILAR ROLE
ARGUED ELIGIBLE FOR VACCINES
UNDER THE STATE PLAN UNDER THE
EDUCATION THE HEALTH CARE
SECTOR. WE CONSISTENTLY RATE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COMMISSION%
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND TODAY
OR TO LEGISLATURE TO INTERVENE
BY PROVIDING DIRECT ACCESS TO
THE BACK BEING THE FRONT LINE
TRANSIT WORKERS PRACTICE
REQUESTED THREE BOARD PROVIDE
EQUAL ACCESS. FOR EQUAL WORK
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
COMMENT THAT'S LINE ELEVEN ONE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI YES.
MY NAME IS EMILY DEAR FRIEND
WITH THE RE OPEN SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M
CALLING TO VOICE OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF PARENTS THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL OCE
SCHOOLS OPEN TO DAY. ARE COUNTY
IS UNDER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND CASE COUNTY EDUCATORS
ARE GETTING VACCINATED AND
DISTRICTS AROUND THE FOR
OPENING INCLUDING GROSSMONT
UNIFIED HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH BUT HIGH SCHOOLERS BACK
TODAY. THIS PLAN HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH SCIENCE IT'S ALL
POLITICS IF YOU WERE TRYING TO
APPEASE THE GARMENT DISTRICT
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT STANDING
BEAUTIFIED SAID THEY WON'T TAKE
YOUR MONEY APPARENTLY TWO
BILLION IS POCKET CHANGE YOU
CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO BEND DOWN
AND PICK UP OFF THE SIDEWALK.
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED HAS AN EXTRA
HALF MILLION UNITS POCKET THIS
YEAR WELL FOR THIRD OF THEIR
NORMAL BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRA EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS NO LONGER THERE THE
CARE ACT FUNDING AND
OPERATIONAL COSTS SIX SAFETY
FROM STAYING CLOSED. STOP
THROWING MONEY AT THESE
DISTRICTS WITHOUT A MANDATE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IT IS NOT
UNLOCKING THE DOORS FOR IN
PERSON EDUCATION THE STATE MUST
MANDATE THEY OPEN ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH LEVELS PARENTS ARE
LOOKING FOR LEADERS WITH A BACK
PROBLEM NOT BEING VERY RICH TO
PUT THIS BILL TOGETHER. SO
PLEASE. I MEAN WHAT. IF I THE
APPROVED APPROACH. THEY STARTED
LEARNING LABS WILL KICK ON BUT
THE TEACHERS AT HOME. SUBSIDY
ARE NOT AND YOUTH CARE EGGMAN
TO DO THE- I ASK YOU SPECTER
LARGEST IT WOULD SHOW AND GET
INTO TO GRADE EXTENT POSSIBLE
AND IS NOT SB EIGHTY EIGHT SIX
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TIME I
SIX ONE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS EVEN
COCKTAIL WITH THE EFFECT OF
SCHOOL AND- ACCESS PLEASE TO
SUPPORT S. EIGHTY THREE AT THE
HAVE A STRONG AFTER ON A- AND
IT WILL MORE. AND SAFELY
STUDENTS BACK INTO THE- I GET
EACH MEMBER OF THE KIM FEARED
ME TO SHIPPING UP AND BALLOT
COMPROMISE. HOUSE WANT TO
EXTEND OUR GRATITUDE JUST. FROM
THE TIME ENERGY AND- YOU INVEST
INTO THE BILL. THANK YOU. WE'RE
NEXT LINE TWENTY ONE TO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND
HAPPY WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO REOPEN
GOLFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
INCLUDING THE ACCELERATED
TIMELINE OUTLINED IN THE
PROPOSED PACKAGE HE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
INCLUSION OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND A GROUP OF HIGH NEED
STUDENTS TO BE SERVED AT ALL
pADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE NEW
REQUIREMENT FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS AND PRIVILEGE HERE
STOPPER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
FOR TICKET THE SECOND GRADE
ALTHOUGH WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
EXPAND THIS REQUIREMENT YOU TO
SIXTH GRADE WELL WE'RE EAGER
FOR STUDENTS AND TEACHERS TO
RETURN TO SCHOOL IN PERSON WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THERE IS A WIDE RANGE OF
COMFORT LEVEL AMONG PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS ABOUT WHEN AND HOW
THEIR CHILD RETURNS TO SCHOOL
IN PERSON DURING THE ACT
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
EVEN WITH WHAT PROVIDE THE
OPTION OF IN PERSON LEARNING
STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CONTINUE TO ACCESS TO QUALITY
DISTANCE LEARNING IF THEY
CHOOSE. THANK YOU TO THAT AND
TO REINSTATE THE PROVISIONS
REQUIRING DISTRICTS TO CERTIFY
THAT EACH STUDENT PARTICIPATING
IN DISTANCE LEARNING HAS WON
THE ONE ACCESS TO A DEVICE OR
AT HIGH SPEED INTERNET ACCESS.
LASTLY WE ARE DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDS FAMILIES SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT A CONCENTRATION BUT
RATHER THAN USING THE POLICY
ABOUT FORMULA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR YOUR EFFORTS WE APPRECIATE
IT. NEXT OVER TO LINE SOME.
ONCE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE- LINE
SEVENTEEN THAT ME. YES THE
TECHNOLOGY WORKING- EXCELLENT
INVERTEBRATE STOPS THE WORD OF
THE DAY THAT IS THE WORD THE
BRILLIANT WOMAN FROM SAN DIEGO
JUST USE INVERTEBRATE. ALL OF
YOU SHOULD KNOW SINCE YOU'RE
RUNNING CALIFORNIA I DIDN'T
INVERTEBRATE IS THE OPPOSITE OF
A VERTEBRATE AND INVERTEBRATE
THERE'S A LIFE FORM WITHOUT A
BACKBONE. NONE OF YOU HAVE ANY
BACK BALANCE YOU ARE BLOCKED
YOU ARE BOUGHT BY. TEACHERS
UNIONS YOU ARE BOUGHT BY
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES YOU ARE
BOUGHT BY THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY AND IN THE PROCESS YOU
HAVE A LOCK YOU DOWN CALIFORNIA
FOR A YEAR AND YES THIS
LEGISLATURE IS RESPONSIBLE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THIS
GOVERNOR. HAS BEEN RULING
CALIFORNIA WITH AN IRON FIST
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ABDICATED YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN NEW YORK.
OUTCRIES AGAINST CUOMO TO
IMPEACH HIM AND THAT IS THE
BUSINESS YOU SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON NOW. INSTEAD YOU ARE LIKE
TODDLERS IN A SAND PILE ARGUING
WELL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
DIED WELL CHILDREN ARE KILLING
THEMSELVES ONE FOSTER CHILDREN
KILLING THEMSELVES AND YOU
PEOPLE CAN'T GET THE SCHOOLS
OPEN. IN THE MURDER BRICKS
THAT'S THE WORD OF THE DAY NONE
OF YOU HAVE ANY BACKBONE AND IT
IS SHAMEFUL IT WAS SHAMEFUL IN
SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN WHEN YOU
KICK FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND. THE
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL WHEN YOU.
FORM A FASCIST LEGISLATION. SB
TWO. NEXT TO HAVE A CALM FROM
TWENTY FOUR TO YOUR LINE OF
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS THEIR ECONOMIC
ON BEHALF OF THE SASSER
REPRESENTING THE FIFTY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. OUT
WHAT WILL BRING IN THIS
PROPOSAL TO OUR INTERNAL
COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON WE DID WANT TO
EXPRESS HOW STRONG OF A
PROPOSAL AND- FINAL LANDING
THAT YOU MADE ON THE CONDITION
OF THE PRIEST WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE
EDUCATIONAL STAFF AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR WORKING WITH US
IN HEARING RESPONDS TO THE
CONCERNS BROUGHT BY SCHOOL.
LEADERS ON BALANCE. WE THINK
THE PLAN DELIVERS RESOURCE THAT
WE TO MORE SO AND PER. WELL
REMOVED THE BARRIERS THAT. SO
DOWN PROCESS. SO WE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS
WORK ON. THESE TWO BILLS THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE TO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ROBERT
MENTORING FROM CHILDREN NOW FOR
SMALL WANTED TO- IT GALLAGHER
APPRECIATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORT ON REOPENING SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDING MONEY TO ACCELERATE-
THAT PROCESS. AND FOR ADJUSTING
LEARNING A LOT IN THE SUMMER-
IN THE OFFICE AND WE ALSO
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PROGRESS MADE TO INCLUDE
ENGLISH LEARNERS AS A PRIORITY
GROUP WE WANT TO MAKE THREE
POINTS- THAT WE THINK- IN TERMS
OF CLEAN UP LEGISLATION THAT
YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER. FIRST
IS AROUND PARENT CHOICE- WE
BELIEVE THAT PARENTS SHOULD
HAVE THE CHOICE TO CONTINUE
DISTANCE LEARNING YEAH THAT IS
WHAT THEY THINK IS AN THEIR
CHILD'S BEST INTEREST EITHER
BECAUSE THE STUDENT HAS SOME.
REAL HEALTH RISK FACTOR- OR
THEY JUST SIMPLY DON'T FEEL
SAFE GOING BACK WE KNOW THAT
THIS PANDEMIC AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND SO
GIVING THOSE PARETS THE CHOICE
IF THEY'RE NOT READY TO TAKE
THE KIDS BACK- FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WE BELIEVE THAT
CAN BE DONE THROUGH AN
INCENTIVE PROCESS- THAT IS ALSO
GOING TO THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE ONE ISSUE
THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE IN CLEAN
UP LEGISLATION. SECOND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING IN PARTICULAR
AROUND CONNECTIVITY AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WAS
STRUCK. FROM THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THIS BILL- WE THINK
THAT SHOULD BE REINSTATED IN
THE CLEAN UP LEGISLATION AND
CERTAINLY WANTED TO POINT OUT
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR- ANY
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT. AND AN
INCREASE IN AWARD ACCESS. FOR
FOSTER THE- THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME MISTER THERE ARE OTHER
LINE AND- OKAY THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
AUDIENCE. I EITHER FINAL
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEING NONE WE WILL ADJOURN
THANK YOU.